[Music]
in anime we often think of conflicts and
fights being the whole my sword is
bigger than yours no mine is even bigger
than yours type of exchanges a lot of
battle shown and actually quite
notorious for that i know that's why
we're going to talk about conflicts and
battles that have this extra depth to
them in this episode we're talking
strategy we're talking big brain plays
and we're talking vast mental reflexes
yes today we'll talk about some of my
favorite battles where planning and
strategy come into play to show you that
even in those fights filled with
fireworks and spectacles there are a few
ones where brains come into play in a
surprisingly creative way do brains
always be brawn in the list we're doing
well not necessarily but those mental
gymnastics sure can get surprisingly
interesting i don't want to keep you
waiting so here are some of my favorite
anime battles involving strategy
despite people knowing naruto more for
the broken abilities and overpowered
character forms i'd say that it has some
of the most strategic fights in battle
shonen now a lot of them came in the
tuning examiner you know when the power
scaling was still low thus the spotlight
shines on shikamaru we've known
shikamaru to be a master strategist
known more for his intelligence and
quick thinking instead of an
overwhelming power or magical eyes
that's why the battle against demari
another master strategist is a match
made in heaven and for the most part of
it it seems that shikamaru was the one
taking the beating he was on the
defensive the whole time only to
masterfully spring his trap that he
planned for in the very beginning it was
a very long term plan and despite having
forfeited the match it's clear as day
that shikamaru is the rightful winner
here
[Music]
when a non-fan watches jojo the first
thing that stands out no pun intended
would likely be the stand battles the
insane abilities that stand users throw
at each other however any fan knows that
a lot of fights in jojo's storied run go
beyond just stands pummeling each other
like star platinum versus the world i
personally find the series of derby
fights pretty good because more than
just people hitting each other it is all
about strategy the poker match in
particular comes to mind and it's a
match full of tension as both derby and
jotaro try to one-up each other in
mental maneuvering not to mention that
with souls on the line the stakes are as
high as ever derby feels tame as a
villain but has that cool factor because
he's one who fights with psychological
warfare it's hard not to show any sign
of weakness in high-stakes poker matches
and that's where his stand thrives him
it's just too bad he found his match in
jotaro
[Music]
hunter hunter's dodge ball match
deserves a mention at least
there are many memorable segments in
greed island but if we're talking big
brain plays and strategy few can beat
the dodgeball match i dare say this part
has become underrated for the quality of
writing but that's more of a testament
to how good the greed island arc is as a
whole of course it's not an anime
dodgeball match without [ __ ] rules
and absurdly high stakes but that's what
makes it so awesome i like how it's also
one of the most intense training
sessions there is in this case it's all
about training hunters to value teamwork
and as selfish as some may be being able
to rally people for a common goal is a
must for any competent hunter the match
has no shortage of drama and i like how
it built character in various places you
see gone selfishness and kilowatt gets
his chance to shine seriously with how
engaging the match was the three
episodes just seemed to pass by and that
formation for the win at the end was a
thing to remember his soul cast stealing
the show once again don't you think
ours
[Music]
next is what i think is an underrated
moment in shaman king 2021 there's not
much buzz with the remake of shaman king
now is there can't blame them when the
anime producers somehow thought zooming
through the plot was a good idea still
it does have some cool moments once in a
while watered down as they may be in
particular i have an x-laws bias and i
think x3 facing off against howe is a
pretty cool moment yep x3 ended up being
nothing but fodder to how but you've got
to give them chops for their ingenious
way of trying to defeat the most
overpowered character in the show it
took numerous lives but the group
eventually finds a way to smartly expose
the spirit of fire's weak point well it
doesn't work because howe has his main
villain plot armor but still this fight
albeit short and having a predetermined
result excels because it builds hype in
multiple ways we see how powerful how
was how the x-laws see each other as
disposable and how creative they can be
when trying to defeat their enemies
up next is grey versus silver
with how its reputation was by the time
it was all over it won't come as a
surprise if fairy tale isn't on your
list of shows with strategic fights but
here we are with the showcase fight and
possibly one of grey's personal
highlights well not his final battle by
any means so do note that there are
still two arcs after this i see this
fight as one of grey's last glorious
moments for himself we get teased to one
of the biggest payoffs to his long story
line with deleora which was originally
revealed in one of the earliest arcs and
silva's words energize him enough to
overcome a seemingly unwinnable battle
through nakama power as we've come to
expect nope through strategy it has some
great callbacks to grey's backstory with
a heavy emphasis on ice shell and he
uses this to his advantage outsmarting
silva with his numerous clones and
finishing the battle
i hope you're enjoying this video so far
because i'm here to ask for some
subscriptions so if you feel that this
content is something that you enjoy
don't hesitate to hit that subscribe
button up there and help the channel
reach that one million sub mark all
right let's get back to the show
no game no life for me is one of the
best itsakai there is and it doesn't
even feature an overpowered protagonist
well in the traditional sense at least
however the pair known as blank
continually show their metal in
outsmarting opponents and overcome the
odds but it would seem that they've
found their match in gibral what follows
is by far the most insane game of
shiritori you'll see in anime and
nothing's topping that anytime soon
whatever you say appears if it's absent
and appears if it's present you have
highlights like sora summoning a
freaking bomb at the start to blank and
gibral bringing out the big guns and
causing planetary explosions with a
healthy dose of fan service in between
classic no game no life fashion mind you
the siblings have shown their
intelligence numerous times this is
probably the most eye-popping display of
it in the series by far blank really
planned for the eventual end game from
the first move i really recommend
watching the series just for this scene
alone plus everyone loves jibril at
least before no game no life zero so
it's a win-win
[Music]
[Music]
we don't often equate fate with
particularly smart fights probably
because we're used to seeing magnificent
noble phantasms like excalibur however
the battle between gire and giritsugu is
actually quite strategic even if it's
not exactly evident at first there are
barely any words spoken in the fight but
it just highlights the excellence of the
scene through the fighters body language
with how much of an expert both of them
are this pretty much boils down to a
one-shot fight where the first one who
lands the decisive hit wins and that
necessitates much strategizing take note
though kirei is the one person kiritsugu
fears in the series and their final
showdown shows just that you can see
that despite the blitzing they do the
actions are planned and deliberate and
the fight visibly takes the time on them
physically as it goes on you don't see
much monologue here but there's just
this appeal to showing something instead
of telling the viewers and this fight
shows that style with pure excellence
i feel that few people talk about world
trigger and it's just a bit unfortunate
seeing as how awesome the series is
spanning three seasons it just kept
getting better as it went on this
particular moment however took place in
the second season here we have border
taking on the invaders in a battle
royale for the ages i like this four and
two because of how much you get to see
the fighters thought process you can
also see the teamwork in play while the
combatants clearly learn and adjust on
the fly shifting tactics while learning
about attacks to prevent and points to
target in the process i also like how
the fighters abilities all complement
and augment each other in this battle
it's an action heavy fight and while
it's not exactly as big brave as
something like the no game no life
moment it is great in how it showed some
of the most important aspects of combat
adaptability and team chemistry in a
huge scale ensemble battle like this
those are must-haves for survival
and that just about wraps up my list but
i do know for sure that there are way
more big brain battles in anime heck the
whole of death note counts if you'd ask
me so if you've got a specific battle in
mind that i failed to mention then
please tell me in the comments section
i'm always on the lookout for new
content so your help will be very much
appreciated also if you want to connect
with the channel i'll be leaving a
discord and instagram link in the
description box so come over and have
some fun patreon and channel memberships
are also open for those who want to help
the channel monetarily that's it for
today hope you had a great time watching
the video and i'll be seeing you soon
you